natürlich will kein anderes produkt von
okay leute scheinbar ist dass das was
deutschland am 6 märz 2018 beschäftigt
platz eins in der youtube trends milch
ist gift kader streichen milch aus
ernährungs pyramide von simon und für
alle die davon noch nichts gehört haben
da geht auch darum was er sagt dass
carla quasi milch aus dem
ernährungsprogramm plan gestrichen hat
und er sagt dass milch gibt ist was auf
mich die reaktion gestoßen ist man muss
auch dazu sagen so youtube bewertungen
sind eure kommentare sind ziemliches
herdenverhalten aber wir mal 8000 likes
18.000 dislike und wir haben kommentare
wie ungeliebt brauchst deine ideologie
nicht anderen aufzwängen geh lieber
bäume umarmen
die mitgift still nach paris also
deutsche das ziemlich wurde genutzt um
kurz was dazu zu sagen ich sag's
versetzte und dann gehen wir auf die
besten milch - ein denn da gibt's alter
erst mal vorneweg wie gesagt ich finde
die polizei endlich ganz interessant
dass man sagt okay vielleicht ist
nämlich nicht so gesund wie man denkt
sollte man auf jeden fall anschauen
solltet die spiele anschauen aber das
krasseste ist wie die leute reagieren
die rast komplett aus dass es so als
hätte man gesagt übrigens milch ist
ungesund deswegen darf deutschland nicht
zur wm fahren aber deutet gelenken jetzt
den hating gute bahnen und jetzt schauen
uns die mühsam das hier postet zombie
die sache ist ja überlegt wie ich aus
der indierock zu streichen und daraus
für sich
oder bist du in so einem video darf
natürlich eine person nicht fehlen die
letzten paar stunden komplett
ausgerastet ist neben league war das 1
ich halte sich alles einfach die maler
ich habe heute dieses video meiner
timeline gesehen ich hab mich weg
geschätzt leute ist eine szene aus
family guy radikal schauen kennen so
diese szene peter imfeld er fällt immer
wieder auf sein bike dann geht es nur so
dass hat neben ich jetzt ein bisschen
umgedreht perfekt gepasst von dem und
bewegung
und da geht es direkt weiter wenn du
einen kaffee bestellt ist und die
kellnerin fragt mit milch das ist schon
geil wie also ich finde es krass wie
heftig reagiert haben gefühle so richtig
krasse gemeinde kommentare geschrieben
habe was ich persönlich nicht verstehen
kann und auch so dass wechsler ausgaben
haben aber wenig sache so mäßig
ausgearbeitet wird es schon was ist das
für ein bild
übrigens hier steht das sieht man heute
noch im biomarkt warum milch gibt es
also kölners abschicken
kann mir jemand erklären was es mit
diesem jahr um ihm auf sich hat ohne wir
zuletzt zeigt sich nur auf diesen
menschen meiner timeline irgendwelche
daten in das profil die verstärker gar
nicht abgeht
[Musik]
das hier ist die antwort auf den tweet
man sie morgen gesagt ihr könnt sagen
was ihr wollt aber ich habe es ein thema
in szene zu setzen so alle menschen die
sie ganz normal antworten diskussion
bleibt dann hier in fünf jahren ohne
milch aber ried wir sieht aus wie
angemerkt auf dem bild
es sieht so krass angela krauß aber
warum sind wirklich lassen wäre das so
plan traten machten zu möglichen trägern
damit ganz kommt respekt dann ist es
eine kastration ist dass die person
stadt dazu weist was auch whisky ist
simon fragezeichen essen taucher der im
coral reef taucht und es ist einfach
eine tüte biomilch es ist gefährlich zu
tauchen oder war glaube ich in der form
auch das original fand ich persönlich
kann da natürlich jetzt keine
veränderungen erkennen an der stelle
muss ich sagen weil so die würde des
menschen ist unantastbar
also nichts gibt einem das recht aller
menschen zu beleidigen erst recht nicht
wenn er sagt dass er mich für gift hält
deswegen hofft dass das ist als jogger
meint das nicht als beleidigung
[Musik]
benötigen sie das hier sollen wir auch
noch ein tier auswich kam ihm dass das
finde ich auch jetzt nicht so krasse
kehrte das gift change ist jetzt ein
festes mit change am 1 aber natürlich
wie kein anderes produkt von vorher geht
es im supermarkt regal
dann hole ich einfach einen liter
giftige milch also keine antwort auf den
song damals gesagt ich weiß dass dazu
sagen dass ich könnte dass wir hier im
detail beschreiben das ist ein 50
jähriger mann auf diesen komischen
ich setze mit acht jahren benutzt habe
damals einfach ganz kurzes video leute
ich bin heute einfach nicht wichtig ob
diese news gesehen von die untere lustig
haben wir deswegen gerade drüber ich
würde sagen aber allgemein leute
informiert zum thema interessiere als
beleuchter ereignis müssen eure eigene
meinung und zum abschluss jetzt immer
für euch
fisch ist da